هاجس الامن السيبراني يرخي بظلاله من جديد
وفي محاوله لخفض التوتر تعلن تيك توك
الصينيه انشاء مركز لتخزين البيانات في
ايرلندا استجابه لمخاوف اوروبيه بشان
خصوصيه البيانات
المنصه الصينيه التي تلاحقها اصابع
الاتهام من الولايات المتحده ودول اوروبيه
اكدت ان عمليه ترحيل بيانات المستخدم
الاوروبي الى مركزها قد بدات بالفعل وهي
العمليه التي ستشرف عليها شركه ان سي سي
جروب للامن السيبراني البريطانيه
عمليه ستعزز وفق الشركه بمركز ثان في
ايرلندا وثالث في النرويج قبل نهايه العام
المقبل ارتباط تيك توك بالصين جعله في
مواجهه الشكوك والانتقادات اذ يتهم منتقد
التطبيق الذي يتيح مشاركه مقاطع الفيديو
القصيره بانه يمنح السلطات الصينيه
امكانيه الوصول الى بيانات المستخدمين في
جميع انحاء العالم
هذا الاتهام ان فته تيك توك المملوكه
لشركه باي دانس الصينيه مرارا وفصلت نفسها
عن بيجين خلال الدفاع عن نفسها مؤكده ان
جميع بيانات المستخدم مخزنه بشكل امن في
سنغافوره والولايات المتحده في المقابل
كانت ولايه مونتانا الامريكيه قد اقرت
قانونا يحضر التطبيق منذ مطلع العام
الجاري ويتوقع ان تحذو مونتانا ولايات
اخرى كما منعت الحكومات الامريكيه
والكنديه والبريطانيه والاستراليه وكذلك
المفوضيه الاوروبيه مسئوليها من تحميل
تطبيق تيك توك على هواتفهم المخصصه للعمل
وبنظام حمايه البيانات هذا الذي يتخذ
عنوان مشروع كلوفر تحاول منصه تيك توك
امتصاص ضغط اوروبا التكتل الذي يفرض
قوانين صارمه بشان الخصوصيه